bei mir geht es recht bündig um unser
Verhältnis zu Ukraine wenn ich von uns
spreche sprechen natürlich von den
Deutschen die eine sehr merkwürdige
Politik gefahren haben die letzte Zeit
die letzten Jahre wir haben ja die
Warnungen der Ukraine das in russischer
Angriffskrieg bevorsteht sehr lange
ignoriert und dann haben wir seit 2014
der Ukraine den Beitritt zur NATO die
ganze Zeit verweigert obwohl die Krim
schon genommen wurde dort was besetzt
war Putin hat allerdings nie ein
Geheimnis daraus gemacht dass er die
Ukraine als einen Teil Russlands ansieht
für ihn ist die Ukraine gar kein Staat
und sie hat für ihn gar keine eigene
Geschichte deswegen frage ich mich wieso
haben wir diese Warnung der Ukraine
ignoriert und meine Antwort jedenfalls
ist es Deutschland einfach das Banale
Interesse hat mit Russland Geschäfte zu
machen das sehen wir nicht nur an
solchen Putin Lobbyisten wie Schröder es
wäre ein bisschen billig jetzt einfach
nur auf ihn zu zeigen es ist auch die
Politik der letzten 16 Jahre Merkel die
verschiedenen Kabinette die wir hatten
ich möchte mal zwei Beispiele nennen wir
erinnern uns sehr in den früheren
Außenminister Heiko Maas der hat auf der
UNO Vollversammlung Donald Trump
ausgelacht was der darauf hingewiesen
hat dass Deutschland sich durch
nordstream 2 nur noch weiter in die
Abhängigkeit von Russland reinsteigert
ich möchte außerdem Olaf Scholz nennen
der heute als Bundeskanzler von den
Zeitenwende spricht der war noch bis vor
kurzem unser Finanzminister und in
dieser Funktion hat er alles versucht um
19.2 durchzusetzen auch gegen den
Widerstand der USA um nicht
missverstanden zu werden ich finde es
ist sehr gut dass wir der Ukraine Waffen
liefern und dass wir die Ukraine die EU
aufnehmen wollen auch dass wir Russland
für diesen Krieg sanktionieren aber ich
finde das reicht nicht denn wenn wir in
Zukunft eine bessere deutsche
Außenpolitik wollen müssen wir alle
diese Versäumnisse aufarbeiten sonst
wiederholen wir die Fehler aus der
Vergangenheit darf ich ihn mit einem
Geständnis Antworten ich habe keine
Geschäfte mit Russland gemacht auch
nicht mit der Ukraine aber dennoch
gehöre ich zu denen die nicht reagiert
haben warum weil ich mir gar nicht
vorstellen konnte dass Putin so dumm ist
diesen Krieg anzufangen er macht
überhaupt aus meiner überhaupt keinen
Sinn für Russland außer dass er das Land
erobern will dass er sich das
einverleiben will es ist eine so
schreckliche Geschichte die noch nie
gelingen die Ukraine zu unterwerfen da
wird es immer wieder stand geben und
Angriffe auf Russisch Soldaten und so
weiter das war für mich völlig außerhalb
meiner Gedankenwelt aber wir lernen eben
jetzt ich frage mich war Putin schon
immer so oder ist er so geworden da habe
ich noch keine schlüssige Antwort drauf
gehört möglicherweise ist er erst so
geworden aber das spielt jetzt auch
keine Rolle mehr für den jetzigen
Zustand er
führt diesen Krieg der keinen Sinn macht
und er ist ein aus meiner Sicht heute
ein durchgeknallter groß russischer des
Boot
der nicht mehr zu kalkulieren ist und
mit dem man auch glaube ich kein
Friedensvertrag schließen kann ich
glaube das nicht ich sage noch mal ich
sage es immer wieder der muss gestürzt
werden ich halte das auch nicht für
realistisch das Putin jetzt auf einmal
einlenkt es ist ja so dass dieser Krieg
wirklich auch strategisch nur dann Sinn
ergeben hätte wenn
putinsvorstellungen die Ukraine ergeben
sich sofort sie empfangen die Russen als
befreien wenn das eingetreten wäre dann
hätte Russland sagen können wir haben
den Krieg gewonnen ohne große Kosten
ohne große Opfer aber jeder der
irgendwie mal in der Ukraine war damit
Ukraine gesprochen hat weiß dass das
nicht der Fall ist dass die Ukraine ein
ein freies Land sein wollen dass die
nicht unter russischer Besatzung leben
wollen
vielleicht lohnt es sich dann sich zu
fragen ja was was diese Motive für den
Krieg sind und sich einfach mal
anzuschauen was Putin selber gesagt hat
schon nicht erst seit letztem Jahr
ich habe es ja vorhin erwähnt
er hat eine sehr merkwürdige
Geschichtsauffassung beispielsweise ich
meine jeder der sich mal mit einem
Ukraine unterhält mit einem Russen
unterhält und ihren jeweiligen Sprachen
merkt dass es verschiedene Sprachen sind
verschiedene Kulturen die zwar ähnliche
Wurzeln haben aber sich auseinander
entwickelt haben und wer ernsthaft heute
noch im 21 Jahrhundert denkt dass es
alles in in einer Art neues Zarenreich
gehört der hat wirklich nicht mehr alle
Tassen im Schrank und die Fehler haben
die Fehler haben mit Lenin begonnen